this summer's dramatic jump in air
travel has caused backlogs at airports
all over the world now one of the
hardest hit of all that's london
heathrow is limiting how many passengers
can leave every day think about that for
a second now that's likely to cause
problems for thousands of tourists who
were there raymie inocencio shows how
big cutbacks during this pandemic have
left airlines and the airports
struggling really struggling to handle
the load
slow snaking lines at heathrow
immigration and rows of abandoned
luggage brits are rushing back to the
skies after two years of coveted stasis
simon calder is a british aviation
expert
and of course the airlines want to make
as much money as they possibly can but
unfortunately while they're taking the
bookings they're not making sure that
they've got the resources to get people
where they need to be those resources
are employees many laid off during covid
many jobs still unfilled getting an
aircraft into the air requires
20 different skilled individuals
unfortunately of those 20 half a dozen
of them are off doing something else not
just in the uk but across europe pilots
and airport staff striking for better
pay leading to british airways cutting
nearly 30 000 flights come this august
scandinavian air systems filing for
bankruptcy protection in the u.s and
more european airlines facing walkouts
but if you can handle the hassle at
departure you might have a happy
surprise on arrival for your next
european getaway
asia but particularly china simply isn't
traveling abroad the number of visitors
from the us isn't going to be anything
like the usual numbers
and who doesn't want just a little bit
more of europe on their vacation after
the din and the roar of planes taking
off but those cancellations and that mad
crush of people they're expected to
continue through october november even
later say experts and we are already
expecting more strikes later next week
vlad
all right raymond ascencio at heathrow
thank you my friend appreciate it